and I have to face chairman kim
jeong-hoon myself directly without any
conditions I will meet with the Chairman
and I would like to have discussion
frankly in complete candor president
Trump has expressed strong support to my
determination as such by saying that he
would support me totally and would not
spare any efforts in assisting me and it
has just announced its intent to
purchase 105 brand-new f-35 stealth
aircraft stealth because the fact is you
can't see them this purchase would give
Japan the largest f-35 fleet of any US
ally Japan will join our mission to send
us astronauts to space will be going to
the moon will be going to Mars very soon
it's very exciting and from a military
standpoint there is nothing more
important right now than space we're not
ready to make a deal and we're taking in
tens of billions of dollars of tariffs
and that number could go up very very
substantially very easily but I think
sometime in the future China and the
United States will absolutely have a
great trade deal and we look forward to
that of Kim jong-un made a statement
that Joe Biden is a low IQ individual he
probably is based on his record I think
I agree with them on that but at the
same time my people think it could have
been a violation as you know I view it
differently I view it as a man perhaps
he wants to get attention and perhaps
not who knows it doesn't matter and I'm
not looking that to hurt Iran at all I'm
looking to have Iran say no nuclear
weapons we have enough problems in this
world right now with nuclear weapons no
nuclear weapons foreign and I think
we'll make a deal I think Iran again I
think Iran has tremendous economic
potential and I look forward to letting
them get back to the stage where they
can show that I think Iran I know so
many people from Iraq
these are great people it has a chance
to be a great country with the same
leadership we're not looking for regime
change I just want to make that clear
we're looking for no nuclear weapons